for months democrats have parroted the
phrase
the big lie to refer to any questioning
of the circumstances surrounding the
2020 election they it's as though
they got a sheet of paper they said this
is the phrase we've all got to use it
consistently for the next six months the
big lie
the big lie the big lie so the big lie
is unfortunately alive and well in the
fever swamps of the far right
well on this date january 10 2019
the big lie of the trump presidency
collapsed but just as the president
spent months
spreading his big lie of the election
after months of pushing donald trump's
big lie the election was rigged against
him no they're not special that's part
of the big lie that the president's been
telling
the big lie the big lie the big lie the
big lie is a phrase associated with
hitler so this is just an extension of
calling donald trump a nazi or calling
him hitler
ironically though because the libs they
know like a very little bit about
history but they don't read past the
first two sentences
ironically the phrase was actually used
by hitler
in mein kampf to refer to something that
he was accusing the jews of doing
that is neither here nor there now
however
a republican leader in the house of
representatives
is parroting the same phrase in the same
sense with republicans like that who
needs democrats
how much longer will we need to tolerate
all these
big liars i'm michael knowles the
michael knowles show
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
welcome back to the show my favorite
comment yesterday from house
and hunter 24 who says hey michael
listening to you and ben saved me from
thinking that this country treats me any
less because i'm a woman
thank you oh you're welcome toots
no i'm only kidding that's very that's
very nice of you i'm pleased to hear
that
john wayne had a line about this many
decades ago
which is he was responding to the
hysteria of the second wave feminists
who said we lived in a patriarchy and he
said that's insane america has always
been a matriarchy
it always has we defer to women women
run the home the hand that rocks the
cradle rules the world
we elevate women this was always the
case
in america this was the case broadly in
the west and in the anglosphere
in particular and it has become less and
less so each day
each day that proceeds particularly
since the tumult of the 1960s
since feminism and women's liberation
the country has actually gotten worse
and worse and worse for women
you can even see this not that i put
great stock into social scientific
surveys
but you can see this in both absolute
terms and in relative terms to the
happiness of men women have gotten
less and less happy every single year
because now we don't value any womanly
virtues
and we treat women as though they're no
different from men in any way
and we we disregard many of their finest
qualities so
yes i'm glad that we have helped you to
see that we value women but
unfortunately
if the libs have their way we will not
value women for very long got to be
prepared for that best way to be
prepared
ready wise now is a better time than
ever to be prepared with long-term
nutritional
food options ready wise has many options
such as
emergency meals freeze-dried fruits and
vegetables for convenient on-the-go
nutrition new adventure meals for hiking
camping and other outdoor activities
ready wise makes being prepared simple
and affordable order online
and have nutritious meals shipped
directly to your doorstep
do not put yourself in a situation when
you need food during an emergency and
you don't have it you need to be
prepared today
if the last 18 months has not taught you
to be prepared
i don't know what will ready wise makes
it so easy all you need
is just some water that water doesn't
even need to be hot and in some cases
you can pour the water right in the bag
so you don't even need additional
supplies just a great way to get peace
of mind this week
my listeners can get 10 off at
readywise.com when entering knowles 10
at checkout or by calling 855-453-2945
readywise is a 30 day no questions asked
return policy
there is no risk in taking the
initiative to get you and your family
prepared today that is readywise
r-e-a-d-y-w-ise
promo code knows 10 to get 10 off so
you've heard this stupid phrase the big
lie
it's just another clumsy extension
of the libs crying that donald trump is
literally
hitler and so they all use it and they
all get the exact same sheet of talking
points and they don't have an original
idea in their head
president trump in response to this
appropriated the phrase
he said 20 the 2020 election is the real
big lie
that was his the gist of his press
statement
president trump has done this before
you'll remember the phrase fake news
which is now totally associated with
trump
actually started as a left-wing attack
on trump it actually was an attack on us
in 2016. the daily wire was listed on a
little google doc that was going around
with other news sites
that the left was saying constituted
fake news
and we people shouldn't read us and
people shouldn't pay any attention to us
and you've heard oh yes all the right
wing news outlets they're totally fake
news so donald trump
appropriated that phrase and said
actually cnn is fake news and he was so
effective at that and
it rang so true that now when you think
of fake news
the first thing that pops into your head
is probably going to be cnn
so you get the dumb line you get trump
appropriating it and then liz cheney
comes out liz
cheney who is a leader in the house of
representatives she's a sort of minor
leader but she runs the republican
caucus there
but she's not really a republican she's
certainly not a conservative and she
seems to spend most of her time
attacking fellow republicans and
agreeing with democrats
liz cheney is parroting this phrase
she's saying that anyone who parrots
trump's big lie
by in any way raising any questions
about the 2020 election which we all
have to admit had a lot of
irregularities just look at pennsylvania
the way that the election was conducted
in pennsylvania was in direct violation
of the state constitution
no one's allowed to say that anymore if
you in any way bring that up
then you're participating in the big lie
you're basically no different than adolf
hitler darn it
and quote you're poisoning
our democratic system
i tried to be fair to liz janey i tried
to be
warm welcoming a big tent party
supporter that says look people might
have their disagreements on trump
we got to come together this woman's got
to go this woman has
got to go she is absolute poison to the
republican party
all she does is give aid and comfort to
the democrats
all she does is attack the republicans
she she won't support the party at all
it is part of the broader problem
of the what you might call the
neo-conservatives
or the war hawk former dems in the three
legs of the post-war
cold war conservative movement the
conservative movement from the end of
world war
ii until the fall of the berlin wall
consisted of what you'd call fusionism
the three-legged stool you had the
traditionalists and the religious right
different but they kind of blur together
a little bit you had the economic
libertarians and you had the neocons you
had the
the warhawk blue dog democrats who
wanted to stop
the soviet union's imperial ambitions
and
that worked all well and good for the
cold war obviously we won the cold war
but the economic priorities
of the libertarians dominated and the
two other groups went along with it
the foreign policy priorities of the
neoconservatives especially
dominated particularly after the fall of
the berlin wall as that coalition
hobbled along
the other two groups more or less went
along with it
but the traditional conservatives never
got anything
we got very very little out of it and
by the way when the traditional
conservatives started to become a little
bit ascendant again
notably during the presidency of donald
trump what happened
the neocons ran away they they abandoned
the three-legged stool so
i'm talking about people like bill
crystal i'm talking about people like
liz cheney i'm talking about people who
who were more from the george bush
george w bush wing of the republican
party people who were more for the bomb
the middle east wing of the republican
party
they just jumped ship the squishy types
left and so just as a matter of party
politics
you can't go on in that coalition
it's it's the the same problem that you
see when a nation descends into civil
war
the only way self-government works is if
people agree
to continue to participate even when you
lose on one particular issue
if this is why the right of secession is
incoherent in a
in a republic such as ours if you can
just secede when you don't get your own
way then there is no self-government
because self-government is predicated on
the idea that we're going to persuade
one another and sometimes i'm going to
get my way and sometimes you're going to
get your way
but we're still going to remain a
country because that's the only way that
we can
that we can preserve even even the sort
of debate
and free government that we're talking
about so if
if liz cheney is she keeps showing us
her cards
and so many other of her fellow
travelers keep showing her cards then
they can't be part of the conservative
movement
because they're they're not willing to
play ball they're they're only willing
to either dominate the movement
or help the dems and that's it so fine
if she wants to leave let her leave but
she certainly shouldn't be in leadership
and frankly i'm not convinced she should
be in the house of representatives
either
talking about big lies big big lies
what is the biggest lie dominating our
politics today
is it that maybe there was something a
little weird about the 2020 election you
know just look at the way the thing was
conducted in various states notably
pennsylvania
no no the biggest lie
is the racial grievance politics that's
the biggest
it's the one that dominates everything
it's the lie that burned the country to
the ground last year
it's the lie that permits legal racial
discrimination in the form of
affirmative action against whites and
asians and in favor of blacks and
hispanics
it's the lie that persistently tries to
rip
america apart and that is exploited by
very cynical people almost exclusively
on the left
to rip america apart it's the lie that
that
our our nation's enemies have always
tried to exploit because there is a
fault line here
right i'm not denying that there have
been racial issues in the country but
the lie
is that america is fundamentally evil
bigoted we can never
in any way overcome racial issues and
that america is a white supremacist
country it's just not true
al sharpton said it the other day al
sharpton was
present at funeral services for a man
who
was killed in a officer-involved killing
these are extraordinarily rare events in
the united states and in cases where
the killing was not justified they
basically do not exist there are
very very few events where the shooting
is not not justified so al sharpton's
there and he says
america is a racist
country now
everybody in america is not racist
but are you talking about whether the
practice of america's racists
or the people because the practice of
america was built on racism
[Applause]
it was against the law for us to rewrite
it was against the law plus the marriage
it was against the law for us to name
our children after
us we were brought here to serve
and never get paid that's how the
country was built
what do you mean america is not racist
america was started off racism
al sharpton is such an odious figure in
politics he's such a leech he's such a
parasite
he he launched his career on a hoax on
the tuwana brawley hoax he encouraged
the riots and crown heights
he's a liar he's a thug he's an
extortion artist
who who shakes down corporate america
and shakes down individuals to fund
his ridiculous slush fund he's just
such a horrific character in american
politics
and he's not that intelligent
but other than that mrs lincoln how'd
you like to play he is very clever he's
very shrewd he's
he's very good at politics obviously
he's he's managed to
make it a long time in politics without
a long time in his
professional life without ever producing
anything he's made it very far
in his career and worn very fancy suits
and flown around on very fancy private
jets
without ever really doing anything other
than extorting money from people
on this premise of racial grievance but
what is he saying he's saying you're
saying america's not racist
what are you talking about we had
slavery yeah so did every
civilization ever in the history of the
world and many still do
we probably had slavery in this country
for less time
than basically any other place on earth
what do you mean america's not racist
slaves were brought here right yep
that's true that was a long time ago and
uh by the way the first officially
declared owner of a slave in the
american
slave system was a black guy he was the
first flight owner was a black guy isn't
that weird that's a weird thing i'm not
saying
that that takes away from the racial
element the racial
character that would develop in american
slavery but the guy's name was anthony
johnson and he was declared the slave
owner of john kaser and actually
neighbors
were very concerned about this poor man
who was supposed to be an indentured
servant and get out
and then this guy anthony johnson was a
black angolan went to the court
and had this guy john caser declared a
slave for life that's just a weird
aspect okay that's a strange thing
slavery all over the world today what
are we talking about though
what he what what al sharpton is trying
to do is
exploit one blip
in the course of history to
rip the country apart today and the
thing is as a political matter
he's got a little bit of a point that
conservatives don't always acknowledge
but what he is doing right now
absolutely disgusting and a lie no
surprise whatsoever
a lot of you know a lot of companies
will lie to you they'll tell you they're
giving you the best price but they're
not you know who is
rock auto rockauto.com always offers the
lowest prices possible
rather than changing prices based on
what the market will bear like airlines
do
why would you spend up to twice as much
for the same parts like let's say for
instance this is just
i'm just going to be spitballing here
you need a delphi fg1456 fuel pump
assembly for a
i don't know a 2005 to 2010 honda
odyssey and it costs you
let's say 354 dollars at the big chain
store that is the kind of thing that you
could get at rock auto
for 217 bucks rockauto.com the catalog
is so unique remarkably easy to navigate
so simple even i
can do it head on over amazing selection
reliably low prices
every part that you will ever need for
your car or truck right now you can head
to rockauto.com
see all those parts available and then
here's what you got to do this is
perhaps most important you have to write
knowles k w l e
s in their how did you hear about asbox
so that they will know that we sent you
that is
rockauto.com
the big lie to use a popular phrase
that america is a vicious awful racist
place and that
our justice system is totally rotten the
whole country is rotten and therefore
the police who are the physical
representation of law and order in our
whole
sense of justice in this country
therefore they are all evil
this pervades the country such that
people now feel that they have the right
to
scream and yell at the cops and
interfere in their jobs i was just going
through the jacksonville airport the
other day this flight just two days ago
i was flying back from jacksonville
and police were arresting some crazy
lunatic who was making a big nuisance of
himself
and certainly should have been arrested
and
but he was a black guy now the some of
the cops were black too so it's not like
this was
a white supremacist racially split
no it's there was a black guy being
arrested as he should have been because
he was making a nuisance of himself in
the airport
and what happens a group of people
crowds around and starts filming
everything and starts screaming at the
cops
tells the cops you don't need to hold
him like that what is this what does
this person know
about how the cops need to hold people
to arrest them starts screaming starts
yelling
we got an incident like this on video
just the other day cop
pulls a woman over because she's using
her cell phone while she's driving
and the woman launches a vile
stream of invective at the cop
harass today because i was going under
the speed limit i was going at 38
yes you are ma'am good morning which is
and the speed limit is 40 and i was
going 38 so why are you harassing you
are correct i pulled you over
because you're a murderer yes i started
to record because you can't be it
you can't be on your cell phone while
you're driving when i was recording you
because you said
may i have your driver's license i it's
it's at my
apartment what's your apartment it's at
my home i'm just taking my son to his
do you have do you have your driver's
license i if i mistakenly left it at
home do you have a picture of your
driver's license
yes i do may have it and can you call
your supervisor please because i already
did he's on his way
because you're a murderer okay
and so you're giving me a cell phone
ticket is that why you're harassing me
not harassment i i am enforcing the law
i have a right to
and record the police when they're
harassing me by all means
but you can't do it while you're driving
i was i can i wasn't
doesn't texting or none of that do you
have
a picture of me and made me think you
were gonna murder me okay well i'm sorry
you feel that way
well you're that's not just a feeling
you're a murderer
does this woman sound like she's afraid
that she's going to be murdered
no i don't i don't think she sounds
afraid of any i don't think she even
sounds afraid that she's going to get a
ticket
because she's playing the race card and
she
knows that this is a lie she knows it's
a lie that the cop is a murderer
because if she really thought the cop
was a murderer she'd be crying and
shaking in her car and she
she wouldn't be screaming at him and and
acting as though everything's gonna go
just fine for her as long as she keeps
playing that race card she knows it's a
lie
but it's a lie to her advantage and it's
a lie that's been incentivized all
around the country in the culture
so she's going to keep doing it this is
also a point that
i think must be made you hear a lot
particularly from blm that the cops
target black people right that's
that's one of the main contentions of
blm and
i can i think a lot of the people who
are pushing that idea are just being
dishonest and trying to achieve radical
political ends but
there are i bet people who believe that
because
everyone hates dealing with the cops
everyone i've been pulled over
so many times in my life because on
occasion i've driven a little faster
than the speed limit
okay and sometimes maybe i've rolled
through a stop sign
and on one occasion i actually didn't do
anything wrong the cop was wrong about
the speed limit
on on a road in new york this actually i
know everyone thinks they're always
right but i'll fully admit i've been
wrong
many times that i've been pulled over or
that i've seen the speed limit or
whatever
there was one time i was actually
writing the cop was a big jerk to me and
if i had been steeped in this culture
where i was told the cops were out to
get you the right to murder you because
the color of your skin
i could see a world in which i'd say you
did this to me because of the way i look
you but no cops are just out there
enforcing the law no one likes getting a
ticket and sometimes the cops get it
wrong
not a lot very rarely do the cops get it
wrong but that's what happens
so so far in this in this video you
could chalk this up
to this woman being incredibly stupid
and irresponsible
right she's saying i can i i you know
i'm going to try to get out i know i was
using my phone but i'm going to try to
get out of it by saying i was recording
him because i'm afraid he's a murderer
okay
that's okay fine she's stupid she's
irresponsible
but then in the next frame you see that
this woman
knows exactly what she's doing and i'm
perfectly legal and i'm a teacher
so there congratulations you're a
murderer
what's your last name i can't see that
there well stop shaking
zoom in on that phone no because you're
scaring me they're threatening to kill
me and my son
can you give me okay you don't tell you
what you keep smiling you're on camera
you're you're trying to threaten to kill
me i've been smiling you're the one
who's
hold that still i can't see that is this
your car yes it is
and you're trying to say i stole my own
car because you're jealous
yeah i don't think so you away from me
right here okay you're jealous
you've got the citation all you need to
do is your signature
he's only citing you for using your cell
phone while you're driving that's it
there you go bam
sign inside the ribbon for him being a
mexican racist
what is that name yes it's on the
citation man
here you go mexican racist you're always
going to be a mexican you'll never be
white you know that right
you'll never be white which is what you
really want to be there you go dear
right
have a good day you want to be white you
want to be what this woman's so awful if
she's a teacher certainly she should be
fired
well michael does that mean you're for
cancer culture yep i'm for canceling her
you bet
because by the way just when some people
throw this at conservatives and they say
well no you support cancer culture
i have never said that people should not
face consequences for what they do
i've simply said that the standards are
wrong the old standards are better
at the traditionals and by the way just
to even take it out of an historical
framework
standards of virtue are good and
standards of vice are bad so yeah the
current cancer culture where you get
cancelled for saying true and good
things
that's bad the old cancer culture where
you got cancelled for being a communist
that's
great i love that we need more of that
so i hope
that that happens i hope that this woman
does not ever teach a student again
if she really is a teacher but you hear
it in her voice
she says oh no i'm just doing this
because you're
you're trying to murder me and my son no
you're she's giddy well she says it she
clearly doesn't realize that she's that
the cop is wearing a body camera
you know the libs pushed for the body
cameras on cops i think because
the very ignorant ones among them the
gullible ones among them believed that
the cops really are just out there
murdering people all the time
the body cameras are going to help the
cops because they're going to show
cynical women like this for what they
are which is trying to get out of a
ticket by making a horrific accusation
and then ironically while she's invoking
racism and racism and racism what does
she do at the end
she says you're a mexican you're a dirty
rotten mexican you're not white
but do you see what's beneath that it's
not enough to just say
see the left they're the real racists
see she's a racist but
what she's doing here is
she is expressing her offense
at the idea that this mexican cop
would not embrace primarily racial
politics inside with her i think she's
black
over the white guy the dig there is not
i hate mexicans the dig there is you're
supposed to be with
me why are you not with me we're
supposed to team up
regardless of the truth regardless of
justice we're supposed to team up
against whitey
so why are you taking whitey's side
you'll never be white
you just want to be white right that's
what she's saying at the end of that
that view how vicious how
despicable how totally cynical where
she's saying
forget that obviously she's been lying
the whole time and
sort of gleefully so but then to say
all right you all right i'm going to
tell you what this is really about
you're a mexican you're supposed to be
on my side but you're on the white guy's
side it's wrong and of course the cop
doesn't see it that way the cup says i'm
on the side of justice
and you are violating the law i have
every right to film you yeah man but you
don't
you're harassing me i'm enforcing the
law
that is a new hierarchy that is race
politics
and it is and adm that woman may as well
admit
directly that the notion of white
supremacy is a farce
it's a joke it's a joke to her she just
knows that the lie
of white supremacy might help her get
out of a speeding ticket or
a cell phone ticket rather that's where
we are you're not allowed to talk about
that
big lie and conservatives don't totally
get off the hook here either
because while it is true that the notion
of
white supremacy or systemic anti-black
racism or whatever
that is a complete canard it's
completely ridiculous
but concern the reason it works is
because conservatives are a little bit
tone-deaf on the racial issue
and the reason that they're a little bit
tone diff on the racial issue is because
they've actually thrown away
the great insights of conservatism
they've just embraced this kind of
shallow
radical individualism that says hey
every generation the world is born anew
and i don't know you anything and you
don't owe me anything
but that's that's actually not a very
conservative insight the conservative
view of the world
is history does matter tradition does
matter
we owe things to our posterity and to
our
ancestors and when you want to make sure
that you can get the absolute
best sense for your posterity and for
your ancestors you gotta go check out
lightstream if you care about the future
if you care about posterity
then probably you're going to need to
think about ways to rearrange your debt
you don't want to saddle people with a
lot of debt and you don't want to throw
money at the window if you're looking
for a way to save some extra money
why not start by paying less interest on
your credit card balances refinance
with a credit card consolidation loan
from lightstream it's an easy way to
save hundreds
to thousands of dollars and lower your
interest rate lightstream offers credit
card consolidation loans from 5.95
apr with auto pay and excellent credit
lower than the average credit card
interest rate of over 18 apr plus
no fees you can even get your money as
soon as the day that you apply i have
seen friends and family
throw money out the window on high
interest credit cards don't do it it's
just such a waste
right now just for my listeners apply to
get a special interest rate discount and
save even more only way to get this is
go to lightstream.com slash knowles l i
g h t
s t r e a m.com slash and old subject
credit approval rates range from 5.95
apr to 19.99 apr and include a 0.50
ought to pay discount lowest rate
requires excellent credit terms and
conditions apply in office you're
subject to change without notice visit
livestream.com
knowles for more information tim scott
gave a slightly you know weak state of
the union response but it was better
than a lot of them we'll get to that in
one second
first though i want to continue to
include you in our future plans
every day on my show i talk about a lot
of amazing products and services from
our sponsors that i
love and use we want to get to know you
better so that we can choose
our sponsors with you in mind so head on
over to dailywire.com
knowles fill out my audience survey to
tell us a little more about yourself
to sweeten the whole experience those of
you that complete the survey will be
entered to win a 1
000 gift card but you can only take the
survey once per daily wire show so if
you want to increase your chances of
winning one
thousand dollars go listen to benchmark
enter cleveland or mount walsh to get
access to their surveys as well
dailywire.com knowles also if you
haven't checked out candace yet
you're missing out especially
considering
that tonight candace premieres live for
free and features a guest that needs
no introduction donald trump
they discuss everything from big tech
censorship to what
president trump's future holds and you
are seriously gonna
figure out some interesting stuff all
right i don't wanna i don't wanna spoil
anything
plus candace has a guest on today in
addition to that special guest
that is really handsome uh really
thoughtful uh really just awe-inspiring
he will leave you speechless uh catch it
tonight 9 p.m eastern 8 pm central only
at dailywire.com if you haven't
subscribed yet you get 25
off with code candace before the
promotion ends on thursday may
6th head on over to dailywire.com we'll
be right back with a lot more
tim scott gave an okay state of the
union response
it's the worst job in american politics
and he was a little squishy on some
points and he was
he was fine on others and okay it was it
was whatever
he then went on the news shows the
sunday shows
to develop his thesis because the state
of the union response didn't totally
land
and i felt he made better points on the
sunday shows
than he did even in that response tim
scott was asked
about whether or not america really is
racist he had a
an important line in that state of the
union response he said
america is not a racist country what
does that mean
al sharpton disagrees with you tim scott
defend yourself
the question is is there a lingering
effect after a couple of centuries
of racism and discrimination in this
nation the answer is absolutely
the question we should be debating and
fighting over
is how do we resolve those issues going
forward
one side says i'm going to take from
some to give to others
fighting bigotry with bigotry is
hypocrisy it just doesn't work
the second our side what i've suggested
is let's expand
opportunity and make sure that we are
fully equipped for the challenges of the
future
okay so a lot of this is just
boilerplate look there were problems in
the past and now we've got to do better
and we want to expand opportunity and
the libs want to steal money from people
but he's making an important point here
that a lot of conservatives don't want
to hear
there is a lingering effect of slavery
just as there is a lingering effect in
the world of all sin
when you when you commit any kind of sin
there is the eternal effect of that on
your soul
where where are you going to go someday
when you shake off this mortal coil
but there is also the temporal effect of
sin
if you steal a candy bar that is going
to
imperil your mortal soul
your eternity right but that will also
harm the shopkeeper that you stole it
from
so you can go to confession and god can
forgive you of stealing the candy bar
but you've got to do some penance you've
got to make up for that because the
temporal effects of that sin
still remain the same is true of
slavery and and of of many other
problems slavery is not the unique
problem in american history there are
many other problems as well
conservatives once understood that
conservatives once understood
that history matters
i think about it when i think of my own
family's history in the united states
half my family came over on the
mayflower half the family came over on a
sardine boat
from italy right so you've got the emma
the irish and the italian immigrants
come over but you've also got the
english settlers who came over early and
settled the country
that gives me a certain perspective on
the history of this country
one feels a certain stake in the country
if one's forebears
helped to build it one feels a certain
responsibility
a certain sense of being at home if my
ancestors came over on slave ships
i would have a different view of the
country now i might still love the
country
i might still go so far as as to say
what some people have said
that they are glad that their ancestors
were brought over on slave ships because
it gave them the opportunity
to live in america and they didn't have
to grow up in some awful country in
africa
i i you could even say that while still
saying
my family's history in this country my
my traditional relationship to this
country
is different than the people whose
family came over on the mayflower
and we have to deal with that we have to
recognize that
the past affects the present and that
will affect
the future in a way i think when
conservatives deny this
we're adopting a kind of progressive
view
of of politics which says that the past
doesn't matter at all forget about the
past past is bad just ignore it
and we're just going to only look toward
the future now what what the
conservative insight here is
is that we want to take what is best
from the past and conserve that
and we want to defer to the tradition to
the wisdom of the ages to the democracy
of the dead
we don't want to just trap ourselves in
the bath in the past and nostalgia is
history after a few drinks but we also
don't want to discard all of it and
start toppling the statues and say
america is a terrible place i think if
conservatives can grapple with that
we will have a bit more credibility when
we point out that people like al
sharpton are just liars they're just
total race hustling liars and that the
idea that the cops are out there
shooting innocent black people it's just
not true it's just a complete lie and i
think
if you if you go far enough as to
recognize people's legitimate sense of
history and tradition
a deeply conservative impulse then our
arguments on where the country is right
now and where it's going
are going to be much much more
persuasive
speaking of history speaking of american
history rick santorum is in trouble rick
santorum former
senator from pennsylvania former
presidential candidate who got pretty
far in the race
now he goes on cnn sometimes poor guy
poor rick but very important politician
has very good things to say he was
speaking at a young america's foundation
event
and he mentioned that the history of the
united states
it derives from the civilization of
europe it derives from the west
it's in our dna you know if you think of
other countries like italy and greece
and china and
turkey and places like that they've all
sort of
changed over time i mean they've been
they've been there for cent for
millennia in many cases and their
culture has sort of evolved over time
but not us we came here
and created a blank slate we birthed a
nation
from nothing i mean there's nothing here
i mean yes we have native americans but
but candidly that that there isn't much
native american culture in american
culture
it it was born of the people who came
here
pursuing religious liberty
to practice their faith
to live as they ought to live of course
of course this is true our publicist
jason campbell over at media matters
clipped this out as though this were
some terrible thing everything he said
they're
totally totally right my only quibble
with rick here is he's not going
quite to the right enough he's i think
he's being a little too conciliatory but
of course
the american culture that we have is not
the culture of the iroquois
okay it's not the culture of the
algonquin it's not the culture of the
cherokee
the culture that we have in this country
derives from
the english and then other immigrant
groups come in and that and they're look
they're
you know people have dream catchers
right so they're they're these little
sort of ornamentations of native
american culture
for a while there was a movement to
pretend that our american system of
government derives from the
from the iroquois or something like that
in new york which is just
not true it means the iroquois had a
kind of confederacy it is not true the
iroquois were a bellicose band of
cannibal warriors
okay these were really tough hombres and
i
i have respect for them as i have
respect for all sorts of different
peoples
but we did not adopt the iroquois system
of government we our system of
government comes
primarily from the english which is what
rick santorum is saying
and that's true so what on earth could
we disagree with here
well rick's cnn colleagues
they they couldn't finish watching that
video without
without beginning to sputter how dare
you say that europeans founded this
country
no contrition didn't talk about
you know the suffering that native
americans have had to deal with
in this country it was i mean rick
santorum really
who did he think did he actually think
it was a good idea for him to come on
television
and try to whitewash the whitewash that
he whitewashed i mean
it was it was horrible it was horrible
and insulting and i apologize to the
viewers
who were insulted by it because i was
sitting in my office
furious because he's done it so many
times
so many times and it's just i'm sorry it
was just
it was so egregious and insulting
and everything that we talk about
about the founding of this country
europeans did not found
found this country it was here the
native americans had this country before
the europeans came
yeah the europeans conquered the country
they colonized it
but they didn't they it was had nothing
to do with the founding of this country
what is don lemon even saying i don't
even know what he's trying to say
because he's saying on the one hand
europeans didn't found this country
george washington was mongolian come on
you know john adams man he was
he was brazilian uh no i think they were
just guys of european stock governor
bradford
you know man he was where was he from he
was russian uh
no he wasn't he was uh it was
english so he's saying on the one hand
europeans didn't found this country when
obviously they did but then he says they
conquered this country
but the indians were here oh yeah that's
true
and by the way it wasn't just an
outright conquest that when when the
pilgrims came on the mayflower they
actually
formed a very mutually beneficial
alliance with massasoit
and with his his indian tribe and they
actually allied together against other
indian tribes and they actually grew
that alliance for many years until
massasoit's
son made a stupid political decision and
launched king philip's war and by the
way some indians allied with
the settlers in king philip's war even
but that destroyed the peace between the
indians and the settlers and by the way
i'm
i'm not totally denying that the
settlers learned something
from the indians around plymouth colony
or
from the iroquois for that matter i'm
not denying that they that they observed
these people and saw some of their
customs and that
had some effect on american life but the
system of government the culture of the
united states comes
from primarily england how can anyone
doubt that
can you say therefore that italy man
italians didn't found italy what are you
talking no there were there were peoples
there before who were conquered
what about the etruscans uh yeah okay i
guess
but they got yeah right they got
conquered and then the country as we
have it today
is not we're not living in the cherokee
nation we're not living
in the massachusetts we took the name
for one of our states but we're not
living
in the massachusetts the wampanoag tribe
we're not living in the iroquois
confederacy we're living in america
which is an italian word from america
vespucci the italian right
we are we have our capital in the
district of columbia comes from
columbus another italian guy by the way
we
the district of columbia is in
washington washington of
anglo-stock yeah of course it's a
european country
he's he's not obviously the the
historical points he's making are very
stupid
but what he's doing here is not even
arguing about historical points because
he doesn't know very much about them
he's doing what hannah nicole jones did
or nicole hannah jones rather
the 1619 project girl in the new york
times
he is trying to reframe the history
instead of disagreeing with rick
santorum on the point of
who founded america he's disagreeing on
the value of that is it good or is it
bad
rick santorum is saying yeah this is a
good country here's who founded it and
this is a good country and what don
lemon is saying is
no here's how here's who founded it sure
i guess rick you're right but it's a bad
country because it was founded on
conquest
you know like every other country in the
history of the world
that is a big lie because it is a good
country and
the the peoples that were populating
this country
before the settlers arrived were
by any standard of virtue not not living
in some edenic paradise they weren't
living in the avatar world
and then the awful mean europeans came
in and destroyed it no
the the people who came to the united
states to america civilized this place
brought the light of god their religion
brought civilization to this place and
because it's a fallen world there were
acts of sin there were sins committed
there was violence there was injury
there bad things go along
just like there were bad things going on
in the iroquois confederacy just like
there were bad things going on
down south in the aztecs who were
ripping out human hearts by
80 000 at a clip in human sacrifices
yeah there were bad things going on
but it was a good thing that the country
was founded that's a reframing you know
rick santorum
is quite catholic this informs his view
of the world he's an actual catholic
we have a president now who is a fake
catholic his name
is joe biden but the washington post
doesn't want to admit that so joe biden
is in hot water right now because joe
biden
is in in outright
abstinence against the church's teaching
on the issue of abortion and the issue
of abortion is not like other issues
saint pope john paul ii pointed this out
it's not just one issue among many the
right to life is a prerequisite for all
of the other rights
one may not disagree like pope benedict
for instance said that catholics may
have a legitimate disagreement about the
death penalty
pope john paul ii said the same thing
and doctors of the church
have explicitly defended the death
penalty blessed pope pius ix carried out
many death penalties
and so catholics can disagree on that
as a prudential matter catholics cannot
disagree on abortion and joe biden does
and he celebrates abortion he expands
the killing of innocent little babies in
this country
so the bishops finally i'm so pleased to
say this
the bishops are standing up and saying
we're going to have to deal with joe
biden here and here's how it was
presented in the washington post
a rising group of right-wing u.s
catholic bishops
is colliding with a very catholic
president who supports abortion rights
right-wing group of bishops colliding
with a very catholic
president everything about this is
untrue everything about this is a lie a
very big lie actually
it is not right-wing bishops who are
doing this it is
bishops who believe in the catholic
faith who believe in the teaching of the
church it is just bishop you just say
bishops
and they're not colliding on this issue
of morals and faith
it's not it's not like well you got the
president on one hand and you got the
bishops on the other
that's not how the catholic church works
the bishops
are bringing the president who is a
member of their flock
into line they're not on equal footing
here the bishops
are reprimanding or
showing that they may reprimand the
president and the very catholic
he's not particularly catholic at all
he goes to mass he apparently receives
communion which is eating his own
damnation to use the scriptural line
and and the teaching of the church and
the bishops in an act of compassion
are suggesting telling him to not
receive the eucharist until he
stops living in the state of scandal and
sin
and changes his views and goes to
confession
an exact flip here but we are told he's
a very catholic president because
it is on the one hand we're told it's
very bad to be catholic right dianne
feinstein
yells at amy coney barrett because the
dogma lives loudly within her the
catholic dogma
we're told it's very bad to be catholic
but then joe biden is very catholic but
the reason that the
left says that joe biden's very catholic
in this admiring way
is because they know joe biden's not
very catholic that his real religion
is progressivism
joe biden is not the only professed
catholic
in politics who is in trouble for
violating basic teachings of the church
nancy pelosi other prominent democrats
in trouble too
archbishop salvatore cor de leone is
now put out a pastoral letter
and not calling out nancy pelosi by name
but he is the archbishop in pelosi's
area
and he is saying that politicians who
are in violation of the church's
teaching here
need to stop receiving holy communion he
writes you're catholic
he's being very complimentary in this
he's being very diplomatic he says your
catholic ideals inspire you in your work
to help those who experience
discrimination violence and injustice
and you deserve the gratitude of your
fellow catholics and our nation for this
service
but we cannot empower the weak by
crushing the weakest
if you find that you are unwilling or
unable to abandon your advocacy for
abortion
you should not come forward to receive
holy communion to publicly affirm the
catholic faith while at the same time
publicly rejecting
one of its most fundamental teachings is
simply
dishonest it makes them all a bunch of
big liars is what it does
and it is not just this is not just a
pure act of punishment
designed to harm biden or pelosi it's
quite the opposite actually
it's designed to help them it is an act
of compassion
and mercy to tell them to stop receiving
holy communion
and to tell them to get their act in
order
because the more that they persist in
the scandal the greater damage they will
do to the society to the faithful and to
themselves
pelosi and biden while professing their
faith
from time to time in catholicism have a
different religion that is the religion
of progressivism
and they might practice both in this
kind of weird syncretic way where biden
goes to mass
right but he doesn't live the faith even
basically we all stumble but he
stumbles obstinately in scandal refuses
to even acknowledge the teachings of the
church
the white house has the temerity to say
yes the president disagrees with the
church on
abortion on the definition of marriage
on this on oh he disagrees with the
church as though that's some casual
thing
if you're a catholic if you really
believe in the catholic faith that's not
a casual thing
but they don't when their syncretic
religion their
catholicism and the progressivism when
they come into conflict guess which
religion wins
it's the progressivism and that is our
state church
that is our dominant church and the high
priest of it i mentioned this during a
speech at the young americans foundation
a month or so ago their high priest is
anthony fauci who instead of the
pectoral cross wears a stethoscope
and instead of the cassock wears a white
lab coat well john oliver is very upset
you know john oliver
that marginal i
couldn't even say it's marginally funny
john oliver who is a british guy
who scolds americans about our system of
government
he's very upset because joe rogan the
other day using common sense
said that if young people are looking at
their risk
of the of contracting or having serious
complications from the coronavirus
then they probably don't need to be too
worried about it particularly when
they're making decisions on the vaccine
that's all he said perfectly ordinary
makes perfect sense
john oliver absolutely furious how dare
you listen to
joe rogan the reason we still see
mask and distancing recommendations is
that the cdc
is being cautious and wants to be sure
that it is not
spreading [ __ ] around during a
global pandemic
like a frozen dinner duke with a tv show
stop listening to what joe rogan tells
you he's a
[ __ ] and those are his words not mine
yeah stop stop listening yeah too i
don't know i guess he's become like kind
of cockney
stupidly yeah well now listen here you
uh
don't listen to joe rogan because you
need to listen to john oliver
does that make sense to you no
i don't think that makes much sense at
all why on earth
joe rogan is much smarter than john
oliver i ain't saying that joe rogan is
uh you know not necessarily a rhodes
scholar or something or that he's in the
academy or that he's
a scientist or a scholar i'm just saying
he's definitely smarter than john oliver
john oliver has never made an
interesting point ever that i have
watched
and he's very rarely made even a
slightly funny point
his his entire brand of comedy is just
saying
otherwise unfunny lines loudly
with profanity interlaced but that is
it's such a crutch in comedy you'll
notice that the best comedians
don't need to do that i'm thinking of
sometimes they do i'm not saying the
best comedians are totally clean they
might use profanity but they don't rely
on the profanity
right the joke is the joke and maybe the
profanity embellishes it or something
but with john oliver he doesn't have a
joke really
he's got these kind of weak lines
samantha b who's another daily show
alumna
she she does the same thing she just
says things loudly and with profanities
if that makes a joke but it doesn't
so why are we listening to john well
because john oliver
is parroting what the cdc says so if
you're parroting with the cdc says that
that makes you really smart that makes
you really trustworthy
because fauci and the cdc they're
infallible they've contradicted
themselves
many times over the last year on this
very issue of coronavirus
vouche comes out he says do not wear the
mask ever
don't wear it it's stupid and dumb i'm
paraphrasing but only slightly
then a few weeks later he says you have
to wear the mask and then when he was
asked well why did you change your mind
what did he say
he said well because i wanted the nurses
to have masks and not you idiot peasants
so but now you can wear them listen to
me and you can believe me because i
would never lie to you except what i
just said
again paraphrasing but only slightly
i to me fauci and all these guys have
basically zero credibility
left and anybody who takes them
seriously like john oliver
has very little credibility and joe
rogan has much more credibility because
at least he thinks for himself
on many occasions but if you're
if you're in adherent to that
progressive faith then that's the way it
goes you know you know where this
progressive faith really exposes itself
in this gender issue a woman just went
viral on tick-tock
because her six-year-old daughter said
that she thinks she looks like a boy
are you a boy are you a girl i don't
know
i don't know who i am you don't know who
you are
what do you think you are you feel like
you're a boy
[Music]
what makes you think that um
so the caption here is my six-year-old
daughter asks me if i think she looks
like a boy i asked her do you want to
look like a boy
her response left me speechless
does it count if yeah okay that's fine
it's available now for pre-order by the
way my upcoming book
the subtitle is controlling words
controlling minds
this woman has left me somewhat
speechless
i'll regain my speech and then give my
thoughts on her
this constitutes child abuse but this
woman might not even know what she's
doing
she might really buy into this idea that
little children
have the ability to freely consent to
major sexual decisions which is
preposterous but you might have the idea
that little children know more about
reality than adults do
maybe they know more than this adult
woman does and she
she might really believe that our who we
really are has nothing to do with our
physical bodies but that is wrong that's
a different religion that is a big
fat lie and as long as we've got
republicans
who have all their guns there are all
their rhetorical guns trained on other
republicans
defending these absolutely absurd lies
on the left much bigger lies than
anything the right's been telling
then those people are no use to the
conservative movement i'm michael nolsas
the michael show see tomorrow
the michael knowles show is produced by
ben davies executive producer
jeremy boary our technical director is
austin stevens
supervising producers mathis glover and
robert sterling
production manager pavel vadovsky editor
and associate producer
danny d'amico audio mixer mike coromina
hair and makeup by
nika geneva and production coordinator
mckenna waters
the michael knowles show is a daily wire
production copyright daily wire
2021 today on the ben shapiro show a
juror in the derrick chauvin trial turns
out to have been a black lives matter
activist
who could have predicted such a thing
that's today on the ben shapiro show
give it a listen